لا لبنان الان حيث وداع النائب العام
متميزي في لبنان القاضي غسان عويدات على
قاضي التحقيق في ملف انفجار مرفق بيروت
القاضي طارق البيطار ومنعه من السفر
للمزيد ينضم الينا من بيروت مراسلنا جوني
جوني نفهم منك اكثر من الذي يجري في
الساحه القضائيه بين البارحه واليوم
في الواقعه سلمى تماما كما كان قرار
المحقق العدلي طارق البيطار قبل يومين
بالعوده الى العمل بعد 13 شهرا من التوقف
مفاجئا لكثيرين القرارات التي اتخذها
المدعي العام التمييزي اليوم ايضا جاءت
مفاجاه لكثيرين ولا تفهم الا على انها رد
واضح ومباشر على الخطوات التي قام بها
المحقق العدلي في قضيه انفجار بيروت لنعيد
رسم المشهد سويا قبل يومين المحقق طارق
قرر العوده الى العمل رغم الدعاء التي
كانت قدمت بحقه لتنحيته عن الملف والتي لم
يبت بها وذلك بناء على مطالعه قانونيه
وضعها لنفسه قرر تخليه سبيل خمسه موقفين
ودعها على ثمانيه اشخاص هم شخصيات امنيه
وسياسيه بالامس المدعي العام التمييزي
القاضي
مذكره واعتبر في هذه المذكره ان الخطوات
التي قام بها طارق البيطار غير قان لان
يده ماتز المكفوفه بناء على الدعوه التي
كانت قدمت بحقه اليوم ذهب المدعي العام
التمييزي ابعد في الخطوات العملانيه
والتنفيذيه والدعى على المحقق العدلي وبعض
المعلومات تتحدث عن طلبه للاستماع الى
اقواله واقرر ايضا اطلاق سراح جميع
الموقوفين ومنعهم من السفر معتدرا ان ملف
تحقيقات انفجار مرفا بيروت ما يزال دون
قادم منذ سنه تقريبا وبما ان المحقق
العدلي مكفوفه يده فهو اتخذ هذه الاجراءات
ماذا يعني ذلك يعني اولا ان اا ما قام به
همم
واضح كما ذكرنا على خطوات المحقق العدلي
طارق البيطار وهو اتخذ خطوات عمليه
كانها لم تكن بحسب ما قالت النيابه العامه
التمييزيه ثانيا هذا التخبط يشير الى
الشرخ الكبير ده داخل الجسم القض
اللبنانيه بشان ملف تحقيقات انفجار مرفا
بيروت وكيفيه التعامل معه وكل اللقط الذي
حصل في الاشهر والسنتين الماضيتين ثالثا
سيكون لهذه القرارات ولهذه الخطوه طبعا
تداعيات ومواقف سياسيه خصوصا ان كثيرين في
الساعات الماضيه اعتبروا ان عوده المحقق
العدلي طارق البيطار الى عمله جاءت بموجب
دعم او دفع خارجي بعد لقاءات عقدها مع بعض
المحققين الفرنسيين في الايام الماضيه
هناك نواب واطراف سياسيين عبروا عن
انطعامهم من هذه الخطوه التي برايهم تضرب
القوانين اللبنانيه وبالتالي طبعا ستكون
هناك مواقف سياسيه كل الانظار متجهه الى
هذه المواقف التي تصدر الى موقف اهالي
الموقوفين الذين بحسب قرار ال- القاضي
غسان عويدات او هو اتخذ قرارا باخلاقي
سبيلهم موقف اهالي الضحايا وهؤلاء كان
ورحب بعوده المحقق العدلي طارق البيطار
الى العمل وايضا تتجاه الانظار الى جلسه
يعقدها مجلس القضاء الاعلى يوم غد في قصر
العدل اللبناني للتباحث بي التطورات التي
طرات على ملف التحقيقات في انفجار مرفا
بيروت علما ان وزير العدل في حكومه تصريف
الاعمال كان قبل يومين احال المطالعه
القانونيه التي قدمها المحقق العدلي طارق
البيطار وقال من خلالها انه يمكنه العوده
الى عمله احاله وزير العدل في حكومه تصريف
الاعمال هذه المطالعه الى مجلس القضاء
الاعلى هو طلب منه ابداء الراي وتقديم كل
الملاحظات المتعلقه بهذه المطالعه وكيفيه
تاثيرها على تحقيقات المتعلقه بانفجار
بيروت اذا هي تطورات متساريه ردود الفعل
على قرارات القاضي الاخيره وهي اتتدا على
قرارات المحقق العدليه
القرارات
ثم غسان عويدات اليوم
اولا بالنسبه القرارات التي اصدرها
المحققه العدليه بما اسمها
النائب العام اللبناني استدعيت محقق
انفجار مرفا بيروت للمثول امامي مثل هذا
الامر ما الذي سيترتب عليه
صحيح
العام التمييزي قد يطلب المحقق العقلي
للاستماع الى اقواله وربما ليفهم منه ما
هي همم الخطوات والدوافع التي همم دفعته
للعوده الى العمل يبدو واضحا ان همم
طلب المحقق العدلي للاستماع الى اقواله في
قضيه انفجار بيروت طبعا الكل سيكون في
ترقق ما اذا كان اولا المحقق العدلي في
الواقع انا فقط الاتصال همم معكم وبالتالي
لا يمكنني ان اسمع اي سؤال او اي مداخله
همم من طرفكم همم اولا كما كنت اتحدث همم
يترقب الجميع ما اذا كان المحقق العدلي
سيتفاعل مع هذا الطلب لانه قبل بعض الوقت
سلطته هي الاعلى في ملف تحقيقات انفجار
بيروت وربما قد يعتبر انه غير معناه همم
التشاور مع هذه الدعوه والثانيه ما جرى
التجاوب مع هذه الدعوه من قبل المحقق
العدلي طبعا قد يكون على الارجح الملف
المطروح مسار التحقيقات ما هي الدوافع
التي همم ادت بالمحقق العديد طارق البيطار
الى العوده الى العمل
والدوافع التي دفعتها الى اصدار القرارات
التي اصدرها وقد يكون طبعا همم في اطار
هذه الجلسه قد يصنع المحقق العدلي مره
شديده موقف النيابه همم العامه همم
التمييزيه في هذا همم الملف التي تعتبر
طبعا كما ذكرنا همم ان يد المحقق مكسوفه
عن هذا الملف وانا كل الخطوات القانونيه
التي قام بها كانها لم تكن شكرا لك